well first thing is that we've collected
a huge amount of data and we've curated
this data so it's it's data where we've
gone typically to sort of primary
sources of data and made arrangements to
get either the static data or a feed of
data that comes in every minute every
second every hour whatever and we've
organized this data so that it's sort of
set up to be clean and computable so
that's sort of the first component is
all this data that exists in the system
whether it's about chemicals or
countries or foods or or nuclear
isotopes or or whatever else or
financial data about companies or
whatever so all this data then sort of
the second piece is given this data how
do we figure things out how do we
compute things it's like you know if you
ask a a suitable scientist you know can
you figure out for me something like you
know where will the Sun be at a
particular time of day at a particular
place on the earth you know if they if
they can do their physics correctly
they'll eventually be able to figure out
the answer or if you have this
particular level of some some substance
in you know in blood what you know what
percentile the distribution does this
correspond to or what does that mean for
the probability of this or that thing so
these are things which sort of in
principle can be computed if you find
the right expert what we've tried to do
is to actually accumulate all of the all
of the algorithms necessary to do those
computations typically that's done by
talking to the world's experts in these
areas and an encapsulating the knowledge
that we get in the form of algorithms
well then another aspect of this is so
it's okay so we know all the stuff we
can compute all these things how does a
typical person who walks up to or from
alpha how do they communicate with it so
that's then another big challenge is to
be able to take sort of the natural
language questions the kind of the first
way that people would think of asking
such and such a question and being able
to automatically understand that and
that's something that wasn't clear
weather is going to be possible people
have been trying to do kind of natural
language processing with computer
for decades and there's only been sort
of slow progress in that in general
turned out the problem we had to solve a
sort of the reverse of the problem
people usually have to solve people
usually have to solve the problem of
your given you know thousands millions
of pages of text go have the computer
understand this our problem was we can
compute a certain set of things and then
were given this very short sort of
utterance that the human has fed us and
we have to ask the question can we
understand that utterance and map it
into the things that we can compute so
it's turned out somewhat to my surprise
actually that we've been able using a
bunch of ideas about sort of
computational linguistics and so on to
make really great progress in being able
to let one sort of type in things in
whatever form on first thinks of them
and having the computer understand them
and then finally one has to figure out
so they're all these things we can
compute we've understood the question
that's been asked there's all sorts of
things that we can give us the answer
which parts of the things that we might
give us the answer should we actually
present how do we sort of present the
right graphical tabular and so on
results to actually communicate in an
effective way with with humans who are
who are using the system so you know all
these pieces we managed to sort of pull
them together and it's all sort of has
to be connected to a sort of a big super
computer type system sort of big crunchy
software engineering necessary to
actually deliver results quickly to
people on the web and so on but sort of
the the main objective here is sort of
collect all this knowledge from our
civilization make it as much as possible
computable get it to the point where
sort of if there's a question that could
be answered by some expert our system
will be able to automatically answer
that question so one's asking sort of a
one might ask a very specific question
you know what will be the value of this
particular I don't know annuity after
this amount with these particular dollar
values based on this thing about
interest rates or whatever else it is so
it's something very specific it's not
sort of give me a general essay about
such and such a topic it's I've got a
specific question give me a specific
answer
you